what would happen if scp-173 the  sculpture was put inside  scp-914 the clockworks rough 173 would  likely be reduced to a pile of dust and  rubble though it'd likely rebuild itself  afterward course we imagine this would  split 173 into three parts head torso  and button legs once again it wouldn't  take long for him to return afterward  one to one we speculate that it turned  into scp-650 the startling statue fine  this could lead to a larger faster  scp-173  capable of snapping more necks when eyes  aren't on it which 173 would very much  enjoy very fine perhaps this would lead  to an scp-173 the size of the statue of  liberty capable of snapping skyscrapers  and stomping neighborhoods when nobody  is looking at it